[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today this
segment is going to be about your budget
and specifically
groceries oh the biggest budget Buster I
mean we're in this season of it feels
like forever inflation and one of the
areas that hits people the most is
groceries that's right so tell people
first of all I'm so excited uh this is
what I call sample time on the Ramsey
Show oh heck yeah I I'm just an absolute
stooge right here and and Jade is going
to walk you through and walk me through
some sampling and you're going to prove
a point here I'm going to prove a point
the point is when especially when you're
in baby step two you're trying to save
money at the supermarket at the grocery
store you make sacrifices you know you
want to get Cheerios but instead you get
our value right or Great Value and so
we've got to make those sacrifices and
here's the thing we're really going to
taste and see if there's really a big
difference in the way it taste because
we know there's a big difference in the
price so Ken so what so I want it for
our listening audience what we've got
here is a round table on the desk yes
and here's what we're about ready to go
through we've got some coffee I can
smell coffee two Brands a national brand
and a much much cheaper brand all right
and then we've got some shredded wheat
looks like yep we've got the national
brand Kellogg's and then the store brand
all right and then we've got some basic
chips no flavor nope basic potato chips
we've got the national brand which is
Lay's right and then now I'm gonna
sample these yeah but no what's worrying
me James and Jade if I can be honest is
I see two rolls of toilet paper I ain't
sampling those oh well no it's not ready
for that we'll put them through the test
though we'll put a test on them so Ken
let's try these chips because
that makes me laugh I like the nice
toilet paper so I can just tell you by
the looks uh we'll get to that what are
we doing first so everybody buys potato
chips you put them in the kids lunch you
can either spend 4.79 on an eight ounce
bag of Lay's or you can spend 289 on the
store brand so so give them a try so I
bring both bowls over here well let me
get some candles I didn't know you were
doing it what am I supposed to do a chip
all right one chip taste it all right
this is a good one
I had to eat it on the mic that's what
makes it either entertaining or awful
it's awful for a lot of people okay
that's your standard chip that's right
there taste this one all right now hold
on I need to like
cleanse my palate okay hold on cleanse
your palate
okay little sip here all right now this
is number two
oh that's some good uh that's good radio
right there did you hear the crunch that
was a great I'll tell you this it's an
obvious winner for me which one number
two number two is the store
and
and you know why I chose it taste and
crunch it's a dollar ninety cheaper
that's almost two dollars
the first one was lays and they were
stale as heck weren't they what's the
other one Publix brand I'm going Publix
brand overlays wow wow wow wow wow and
part of a chip by the way for a guy I'm
speaking on behalf of all men so ladies
listen to this
part of eating chips for guys is the
sound
I want to hear it crunch
since you like the crunch now we're
going with cereal all right standard
standard Shredded Wheat right Kellogg's
by the way true story never had shredded
wheat in my life ever first time right
now and then we've got the store brand
so let's pour some milk in the cereal
for the people listening you're actually
doing milk I'm doing milk I've never had
milk in my I don't put milk in myself
first of all that's not milk for our
listening audience that's oatmeal well I
have to be able to try what's up two
percent man give me the lactose all
right get you a spoon Ken a spoon and
taste one of these folks I get paid to
do this I just want to point this out
okay this first time ever yeah I like
Shredded Wheat but I just eat it dry you
also like oat milk here we go
I didn't slurp did I no no you didn't
slurp you could slurp it on the radio
though people like that all right all
right that's the first one what's next
okay use your same spoon and try the
second one because I want to try this
all right all right how we doing on time
James we're doing good our fearless
we're good we're good okay I'm gonna
taste this one too first of all no one
should ever eat anything with oat milk
let me just tell you that right now
I don't understand how if life if you
got to be healthy and this is what life
is like that's kind of good I don't want
to live it that's kind of good I like it
I put orange juice on my cereal okay
clear winner again what's the one first
one that's the story
I don't know what's going on again
apparently I am a generic dude guys and
by the way take it away from this this
is a blind taste test only I know which
one is the store brand I have no clue
it'll come as no surprise to anybody
okay so Ken what you're saying is I'm
selling brand which is a 1.88 cheaper
again almost two dollars difference is
better tasting it is is it because
they're putting more bad stuff in it
I'm just asking you're the health coin I
don't think so you're one of the
cleanest eaters I know here's the thing
most of these uh store brands are made
at the same manufacturer as the national
brand it's the same thing they just slap
a different label on them well if it's
the same thing why do I keep picking the
cheap brand I don't know I think they
taste I'm telling you that the cheap
chip tasted different I'm saying it did
it had the crunch now let's try this
this coffee coffee is what we have here
you guys know of course it's better to
brew it at home than Starbucks but in
this case is this mine here yeah that's
yours now I'm gonna put a little creamer
in my coffee I'm gonna drink it black
just because so you can really get the
taste because I want to judge them okay
okay yes I won't do cream so the first
one here we go first one down the hatch
is this gonna burn my tongue so I can
sue you do I get to sue Dave if I burn
my mouth
I'm kidding stop it that's gonna be on
social media later oh my gosh
taste it
okay all right okay golly oh that's nice
you people that drink coffee black and
act like you like it I want you all just
own it you're lying to me what are you
saying I like black coffee this might as
well had a shoe bottom in there then
that means it's not good no all black
coffee is terrible no it's not see it's
not a manly thing I'm man enough to go I
want some sugar and cream in my coffee
can I oh man I have my choice all right
number two
that was off that was Dreadful okay this
one was this one
I'll put it
oh gosh yeah number two is even worse
than number one all right so on that one
here's what we did the national brand
was Pete's you guys have heard of Pete's
Coffee yeah and then the 5.99 brand was
Cafe bustilo which is a Latin brand
which I like I thought that that one was
better because I like a full bodied but
guys which one's cheaper Cafe bustilo
it's five nights the cheaper one no you
chose the expensive one because you're
bougie kin but I chose the less
expensive one apparently I'm not I mean
it's a seven dollar difference 6.60 all
right so now we're starting to in the
budget here we're gonna come back to
this so maybe I scrimp on the chips and
I pay a little more for the coffee I
mean we're working our way through this
or maybe just put creamer in the coffee
oh
all right now there's a big one can
toilet paper I'll see I don't even have
to well I'm not sampling it so what am I
doing I mean I gotta touch it I'm
touching it it looks like it's got a
decent ply to it oh okay I can hold on
I'll wipe my nose I don't have anything
yeah blow your nose let me let me just
let me just
okay come on I can't okay we're good
James well let's think about this the
Charmin for the same amount the Sherman
7.79. okay and the Angel Soft
is this Angel it's 479 well I don't know
you told me don't be reading it just
look at it oh I didn't read hold on I
gotta wipe my nose really quick okay
that is a three dollar difference oh
there's no question there's no question
uh the the second one is much softer on
my nostril it's softer but will the
first one get the job done Ken that's
the question when it comes to toilet
paper I don't want John Wayne toilet
paper you know what John Wayne toilet
paper is it's rough and it's tough and
it won't take crap off of it
sure what to say I don't want you
to get right into that one all right so
which I chose uh toilet paper you chose
Charmin which is three dollars more
expensive I'm gonna pay three more
dollars for my bottom look I'll be
honest with you I am team Angel Soft
that's what we bought when we were in
baby step two and look it's a short-term
sacrifice for a long-term gain you your
bum will be okay I tell you what I'm
doing then let's talk real budgeting
real budgeting what if I I go generic
brand I save all that money on
everything else but I spend on the soft
double-ply toilet paper I say do what
you got to do Ken again we're making
trade-offs this is trades you know you
can say hey I'm willing to scrimp on
this in order for me to have a little
bit extra to buy that walk through this
how much money could we save if we go
generic brand across the board all the
way up and down the old list oh hundreds
per month hundreds there it is easily
hundreds we just now just right here we
saved ten dollars
and budgeting and everything else come
on and go to my insta
that's where it's at yeah Ken this was
fun hey we saved people some money
um I'll be honest with you though I
wouldn't scrimp on the toilet paper I'm
going premium team Angel Soft all day
give me my three dollars back no oh